we care about you and we congratulate
you on what you've achieved all of us
here today are and forever will remain
part of the same community the Columbia
community there is a tradition here by
which to chart your life's course to
aspire to and to answer to this little
world you have been in idealizes the
virtues of deep and open thought and the
power of reason and human insight the
much bigger world you are entering
values the need to deal effectively with
the very real problems it has and the
opportunities to be better than it is
now
the two worlds exist in parallel each
needing the other and we both need to
improve here we need to answer more than
we are now the call for help on solving
the most pressing and mystifying issues
the world has ever seen
the real world needs to embrace more of
the intellectual character we try to
practice here there are three areas of
concern the denial of expertise most
vividly and disturbingly represented in
those who would reject the consensus of
the scientific community about human
induced climate change the second the
second problem is the hardening of
beliefs and intolerance as witnessed in
the unwillingness and of many in public
discourse to at least entertain the
possibility that others may have better
ideas which inexorably leads to
intimations of violence and finally
there is the corrosive attitude now
prevalent in public debate that the less
said the better because expression of
your viewpoint can only get you in
trouble
sadly represented in their current
inability to discuss and debate what the
constitution of the nation does and
should mean beyond simplicity's such as
we must follow the original intent
of the founders these three afflictions
the denial of expertise the intolerance
and the retreat into silence would be
the death of our universities and they
will be if allowed to prevail the death
of our democracy
you have been steeped in the culture of
having to state your views explain why
they make sense consider alternatives
and abide by the results of a process
that transcends your own wishes about
what you would like to believe you have
plunged into the complexities of
subjects and kept your cool now we plead
with you to take these intellectual
habits of mine into the political arena
leading a new generation in the process
this is your tradition in the mists of
the beginning of this nation
when Americans had proven themselves
quite capable of taking up arms in
bloody revolt against governments they
didn't like and informing themselves by
reading a highly partisan press filled
with scurrilous personal attacks some
were able to frame the contentious
battles over the very nature of the new
federal union into a model of coherent
reasoned advocacy through the classic
Federalist Papers and two of the three
authors Hamilton and Jay were Colombians
and not just not just names on those
buildings over there in the corner this
is your heritage and this is your
mission to be our new Hamilton and Jay
the world needs you and we send you into
it with confidence there's clearly no
shortage of work to be done
congratulations and good luck to the
class of two
you